where this education conference we are
you were just saying I always hear the
strangest places it's amazing it's it's
a Warriors game actually wouldn't
mention the Warriors but this education
thing is a lot of money because a lot of
publicly traded companies or a lot of
investments going on you've made
investments in education when you look
at the world of Education as an investor
or a person what do you see as being
screwed up well I think they're good
they're gonna be a lot of universities
that go out of business and I'm not
talking about Apollo's and the you know
University of Phoenix type for profits
but schools themselves seeing some of
that Clinton colleges right yes right
but if you look you know sweet Breyers
you're starting to see some some changes
right and I think what people and
investors fail to realize is that let's
just say for the sake of example school
style charges forty thousand dollars a
year for tuition you lose a thousand
students that's forty million dollars a
year there aren't a whole lot of
companies particularly education type
companies that can can adjust to a loss
of forty eight forty million dollars so
what's happening and I'm looking from an
investment perspective for companies
that support keeping kids in school
because if a kid goes through school and
for you either postgraduate level no no
college college college or post graduate
for that matter but if a school keeps a
kid and graduate some in four years
that's a much more cost-effective
graduation for the school so Ron ku
which helps attract students payback
which makes it more cost-effective for
books for kids to get books Chloe um
produce it yep retention system which
helps keeps kids in school with
counseling systems those help help
schools reduce their costs so they can
deal with the ups and downs and
demographic changes as kids go in or
don't go to school so one of your
investments is a comfort of just just
that it monitors user sort of big data
at a monitor talk about that I kidding I
never Browns teach last name rights the
clarity retention systems right so what
they do is they help they help schools
put together monitoring systems so when
kids are doing things on their own
schedules where you have to turn in
things particularly their online
students you want to be able to monitor
to them and if something isn't happening
on time you want to be able to send an
alert not just to the student
but to the school as well so they could
be they could proactively take measure
because these schools have these
advisers and it wasn't like that when we
were in school I think this wasn't well
they had all right we just never used
them right I wonder though you know for
those schools when they look at this
they've got a whole different
interaction with a student because it's
happening digitally and it's not just in
a classroom there's exactly right so
it's not it's not the traditional way
that we were used to where you go to
class you take roll call and either
you're there you're not right now it's
completely different you know portion is
online or all of it is online and you
want to know it's not just about taking
the test at the end of the semester like
we used to just so often do you know so
you want to know if the kid is tracking
to make sure they're reaching their
milestones in order to be successful
because you know it's it's harder to
self monitor when you're taking online
classes or just general the weight
classes are today in colleges one of the
other things is changing a lot is the
way the books work the way I know you've
looked at that for investment yeah one
of my Shark Tank companies is packed
back books right and what they've done
basically is it's not backpack it's
packed backpack yes my dyslexia coming
no no I get it all confused all the time
anyways really before coffee but what
they're trying to do is re-engineer the
whole eBook approached to college
textbooks and they're working with
publishers now to try to come up with
analytically the best approach to
selling textbooks not just the physical
textbooks but ebooks replenishing ebooks
and in some cases kind of a pay-per-view
for books as well so that you know you
may just need you know you may be like
me I didn't buy the books as I couldn't
afford them right when I would borrow
books or the borrow books borrow books
now you can rent them for a limited
period of time so trying to create
almost a windowing system like the movie
business so that you can get your books
at the way you need them when you need
them at the price you need them and
create new revenue streams for
publishers the publishers want that
though because their business of selling
books that can open two three times
thirty a business say they're learning
they don't have a choice
right because as school gets more and
more expensive it's one thing when you
know your books were you know
a set amount right and you had to feel
but now as college tuition has just
dramatically just expanded and grown so
rapidly like three times the rate of
other inflation yeah rate of any other
inflation what's happening now is that
the marginal cost of those books appears
to be enormous and kids aren't always
making the choice to buy them or they're
renting them or they're they're buying
them used and so they're not getting the
Renewable revenue sources that they used
to pack back now comes in and says okay
we're gonna analyze that for you come up
with the best solution and you're gonna
and you got that one out of shark tank
yeah there are you making money on those
investments yeah I've had one one go out
of business - that should be out of
business but they aren't smart enough to
know it and the other 30 some are doing
well and how do you do that you you
allocate a certain amount of capital
towards that ideal here no I mean a
fortune in that I don't have to limit my
capital allocations so I just tried to
find great one you've the strangest
investment follow the philosophy of
anyone have known with money well you
seem to just sort of like yeah it is but
you know on Shark Tank is one thing
because I'm trying to support
entrepreneurs as much as I am you know
if I'm outside of Shark Tank I'm looking
for homeruns right so when I invest in
Cloward is when I investor go wrong COO
who helps companies go out and find new
students and find the best outcome based
on values for students then that's a
different type of investment than what I
do in Shark Tank I don't know if I've
ever told you my favorite Mark Cuban
story when you weren't involved let me
tell you that ok broadcast.com days two
guys are standing by the water cooler
I'll tell you the names later I went off
the air but one guys they're talking
about something and you walked up to him
and said to one guy is he trying to sell
you something and he said no no no mark
you said we're just talking he said to
the other guy is he trying to sell you
something no no and then you said to
them if neither what are you selling
something then you don't need to work
here if you're not selling something
leave if you're gonna sell something go
to your Jeff before it and and you may
remember that incident or if you do that
all the time right
if two people are talking and no one's
writing a check you're wasting your time
so is is that the approach you bring
your investments where you try to say I
know you did it with the Mavericks where
you took over a team that was really
struggling and got people on the phone
and call up
yes I mean I always say sales cures all
right if you don't have any sales you
don't have a company who has never been
a business to survive without sales but
on the flip side things are a little bit
different now because there's no IPO
market and so now you almost have to do
things that that are different
milestones in the short term in order to
set a platform to be able to raise money
or get to profitability much more
quickly so now I mean I'm allah-allah
the company's the platform but then you
immediately have to go to revenue unless
there's something just dramatic about to
happen so but we still see that in
Silicon Valley we've got the snapchats
and the Pinterest and companies that are
out there for a long time but even
though that's changing rapidly now
because once you get and you're that
unicorn right and you've raised a
billion dollars you've raised five
hundred million now you're seeing them
seeing them accelerate your revenue
because in order to do an IPO you have
to outperform right you can't just be
you know an increased 30% a quarter he
increased 40% a year you have to blow up
your numbers and that's why you've seen
snapchat go to what they're doing you
know at 7 or $50,000 for this or that
and you start you know yeah what's up
good spot because they don't have that
revenue outlet so really revenue has
become far more important it's gone full
circle because back in the day with
broadcast comm you can do a 30 million
dollar IPO now I just read something
yesterday there were more 100 million
dollar financing private finances from
VCS then the war were IPOs right even
during the bubble yeah you know now now
now over the last 10 years more IT
companies have grown through private
investment than through IPOs there was
only like 231 IT companies that have
grown through IPOs over the last 10
years that's crazy so what so because
there's no IPO market because the SEC is
screwed that up dramatically I have to
get that dig in there you have to change
all your strategies and how you deal
with companies and how you expect them
to grow or weaken this last question
we're going to see a unicorn like that a
billion dollar private company in
education because we haven't seen it yet
oh yeah yeah I mean again because
there's no outlet for IPOs I mean you
seen Chegg which is you know had a great
turnaround and their stock price has
gone up but outside of them you're not
seeing the traditional growth path from
the 90s where again you so you show
dramatic growth you show hints of
profitability
then you go to the public markets to get
capital to grow now you have to keep on
raising money privately or get bought
out and until that IPO market reappears
maybe raiga a plus will change that but
until it reappears then you're the
smaller IPO market yeah the smaller idea
you're going to see a lot more unicorns
because they don't have the outlet to go
public so you will see a billion dollar
education unicorn the question is what
happens next because you're also going
to start to see billion dollar unicorns
go out of business
say funds so come